These next few videos will explain the final project. And give
you guidance before you get started working on it. Now, if you're
enrolled in the full course experience you should complete the project. And
learn how your project's going to be evaluated. If you're enrolled in
the free courseware, you can still complete the EDA project to
showcase your skills. But you won't be submitting the project to Udacity.
Now, you might be wondering what should go into your analysis and
how it should be formatted. We provided an example that is linked
in the instructor notes. The example is an analysis
of the diamond status set. And you should pay careful
attention to how observations and questions are interspersed through
out it. It's almost like a stream of consciousness of
an analysts thoughts. And you should do the same
exact thing when conducting your own analysis. Now, if you
haven't already, go to the Instructor Notes. Download the example
and the instructions to complete your analysis and get started.